lors d'une récente interview accordée à
la presse et à la télévision omar sharif
a affirmé avoir maintenant en vie deux
banques
fini les voyages précipitée et les
hôtels offrent à chercher pour cela il a
choisi de s'installer à troubles bien
entendu ce choix s'associe à l'idée de
donner un second souffle au casino de la
ville
sage décision qui lui permet également
de passer ces quelques instants de
liberté en compagnie de diar son chien
un solide braque allemand et les deux
dernières recrues mardi et banco le plus
jeune deux chats abandonnés qu'il vient
de recueillir
et
chez moi par exemple mes parents étaient
des gens assez aisée mais qu'ils étaient
préoccupés par le jeu par les cartes qui
n'avait vraiment pas le temps de
s'occuper d'animaux
c'est à dire que j'ai grandi sans jamais
avoir même changé avoir un animal à la
maison voir des animaux dans des maisons
d'autres gens des amis ou des gens qu'on
connaissait
c'est une chose tout à fait nouvelle
c'est uniquement depuis que je suis je
suis en europe que je suis entouré
d'amis il y a eu un sentiment de
solitude dans ma vie d'abord du fait que
j'étais d'une certaine façon exilés de
mon pays puisque je vivais dans aux
milliers de gens qui étaient tout à fait
nouveau un monde nouveau j'avais j'étais
entré dans un monde nouveau qui était
très différent du monde oriental très
chaleureux plein de sentiments humains
très mélodramatique et j'ai je suis
arrivé en europe et aux états unis en
angleterre en france où les gens
extériorise beaucoup moins leurs
sentiments et j'ai éprouvé un sentiment
de solitude de sécheresse si vous voulez
du point de vue des émotions et des
sentiments qui a fait que je me suis
tourné vers les animaux et que j'ai eu
le besoin d'être entouré d'ennemis
est ce parce qu'ils font partie de
l'impalpable ou de l'inconnu plus
exactement
ou alors sont ils un équilibre recherché
pour stopper un peu votre tempérament
d'aventuriers de
heures c'est-à-dire il ya plusieurs
éléments qui entrent en jeu
le principal pour ma part c'est que
j'aime les animaux naturellement c'était
l'amour naturel que j'ai bourgeois je
leur trouve une énorme gentillesse et
puis il c'est un besoin d'affection que
j'ai dans donné d'en recevoir
je vais je
je vis seule je n'ai pas je ne suis pas
mariée dont je suis divorcée et j'ai un
besoin d'affection d'en donner comme
jeudi et de recevoir et les animaux me
donnes ça d'une façon fantastique et des
sons d'une grande fidélité je trouve à
l'aube une douzaine de chevaux et là
j'en achète tous les anges et je cherche
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle vous
continuez à travailler c'est uniquement
pour acheter plus de chevaux et pour
entretenir les jours qui passent les
chais et pourquoi votre préférence pour
cheval par rapport aux autres zones
immobilières
parce que ces nobles le cheval je le
trouve noble est beau et dj c'est un
geste magnifique le geste du cheval je
veux dire quand on regarde l'encolure
d'âge oil je trouve ça d'une d'une
beauté extraordinaire juste j'ai même
une passion pour les peintures et les
sculptures de cheveux je trouve les
formes des lignes d'un cheval sont les
lignes les plus harmonieuses qu'on
trouve chez les animaux personnellement
puis j'aime ce tempérament un peu piaf
heures un peu nobles comme on dit chez
nous enfin
j'ai une douzaine de jours donc une
jument en particulier je crois que j'ai
été amoureux de cette union est vraiment
amoureux d'elle ça a été une pouliche
que jamais il acheter dès que je gagnais
mon premier gros cachets et qui a été
très bonne et qui était très féminine et
des très belles
il
m
elle était presque infirme
elle avait donc elle était ce qu'on
appelle khâgneuse c'est-à-dire qu'elles
marchaient très en dedans les les mains
étaient très en dedans et elle était
très féminine est très belle et j'en
suis tombé amoureux et c'est dûment et
cette pouliche donc à cette époque est
avérée une très très bonne pouliche de
course qui s'appelait jean ping turn
vers le rose et elle m'a fait une très
bonne carrière de course ensuite j'ai je
les envoyais au raz el ma produit que
des gagnants tout la progéniture de
cette jument à des noms avec le mot paix
rentrent dedans et si c'est pour moi
c'est ma famille dire c'est une famille
qui m'appartient khaimah véritable
famille tous les chevaux qui s'appelle
peur quelques roustes
j'ai l'impression que c'est c'est à moi
que ça fait partie de mes enfants j'ai
un amour absolument gigantesque pour
ceux du mois pour toute la famille